NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY THE CRYING
GAME, THE CRYING GAME.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I'M GOOD AT THIS.
THIS IS WHERE IT TURNS OUT I
HAVE A DICK.
>> OH.
[LAUGHING]
YES.
>> Chris: THE TERRIFIC SITE AND
PUBLISHED A BOOK CALLED
REASONSMYSONISCRYING.COM
COMPILES COLLECTIONS OF
PICTURES SUBMITTED PARENTS OF
THEIR KIDS HAVING A NERVOUS
BREAKDOWN AND AN IRRATIONAL
EXPLICATION TO WHY IT'S
HAPPENING. FOR EXAMPLE, THIS
LITTLE ANGLE.
ACCORDING TO HER MOM, SHE'S
CRYING BECAUSE SHE SAYS I
WOULDN'T OPEN THE STRING CHEESE
FOR HER. IT WAS A TAMPON.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: THE LITTLE ONES.
DON'T GROW UP SO FAST.
IRRATIONAL CRYING AND TAMPONS
WILL COME SOON ENOUGH.
COMEDIANS, I WILL SHOW YOU A
REAL PHOTO OF A REAL KID.
FOR 250 POINTS GIVE ME YOUR BEST
GUEST AS TO WHY THEY'RE CRYING.
HOW 'BOUT THIS WILL GUY.
LOOK AT THIS PEANUT.
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE, KEV.
>> CLEARLY THAT BABY IS OUT OF
COCAINE.
HE'S HAVING A ROUGH NIGHT.
>> OH, WELL HE --
>> I MEAN HE HAS, HE HAS TO GET
TO WILL WHEATON'S CHRISTMAS
PARTY. OF COURSE HE --
>> MOM I HAVE BEEN UP FOR 36
HOURS.
>> Chris: WILL.
>> GORDON RAMSEY TOLD HIM HE'S A
TOOLENTED LITTLE [BEEP] --
>> Chris: OH. POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> YOU THINK YOU'RE MAKING
MELON THERE, YOU'RE [BEEP]
MENTAL.
THIS IS WHAT THE ACTUAL ANSWER
IS.
HE SNEEZED INTO THE FLOUR.
PRETTY CLOSE TO KEVIN'S.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE THIS.
THIS BABY HIPSTER.
GOD DAMN IT. PEREIRA.
>> I THINK HIS INSTAGRAM ONLY
GOT FIVE LIKES.
>> OH, MAN.
>> IT WAS A REALLY ARTSY
PHOTO OF SMASHED PEAS.
>> Chris: YUP.
>> MAYBE WILL WHEATON
SNAPPED AT HIM FOR SENDING A
STAR TREK VIDEO.
>> Chris: YUP.
KID GOTTA LEARN.
>> I [BEEP] TOLD YOU LAST TIME.
YOU LITTLE [BEEP].
>> I FEEL FOR THIS KID.
HE'S LIKE I WANTED TO GO ON THE
WEEZER CRUISE.
>> Chris: ALRIGHT.
THE REAL ANSWER IS, I FLUSHED MY
POOP BEFORE I COULD LOOK AT IT.
SO WAY WORST THAN ANYTHING WE
SAID.
>> I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> CHRIS: WHAT WORSE. OK, LAST
ONE.
THIS STRUGGLING LITTLE FELLA.
>> AHHH.
Chris: HE'S TRY TOWING MAKE
IT WORK.
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK.
WIL.
>> HE'S [BEEP] REVERSE COWGIRL.
[LAUGHING]